with forty three percent turkey on the
third place nineteen percent and Russia
on the fourth place seventeen percent so
that means that Poland well unlike in
Poland Poland and Paul polls are being
referred to rather positively I'm
referring to the result of the public
opinion poll body of the Ukrainian
expert conducted by the Center for peace
conversion and in foreign policy of
Ukraine recently two-thirds of
Ukrainians we're considering considered
Poland as the best partner to help
Ukraine to join both NATO and European
Union so that means that Ukrainian
public opinion is relying a great
expectations on our neighboring country
poland now i would like to conclude with
some remarks how and what could be the
future of our relationship first ukraine
and poland can and should be the leader
in the region and together can play a
stabilizing role in Central and Eastern
Europe and the Europe as a whole Poland
can be a strong driving force in both
European Union and NATO to promote
Ukraine's interest and I would sincerely
hope that it will be the case the third
Ukraine and Poland can and should play
again leading role in pushing galleries
towards democracy and to the united
Europe before Ukraine can and must
repeat in the near future the Polish
example by joining both European Union
and NATO in future Ukraine and Poland
will define and
influence the position of Central
European countries in the enlarged new
Europe and together in both NATO and
European Union so these are just short
remarks and I think that much would
depend whether this predictions will
have the chance to be realized and not
only from Poland Poland has done its job
very good but much depends on Ukraine
thank you very much thank you very much
for your kind introduction to reminded
me my years here in New Yorkers as well
where I was one of those who created
committee subcommittee in support of
solidarity that time yeah so I am to
speak about the future today it gives me
certain freedom possibility to speculate
be carried away with away the kind of
imagination but before I speak about the
future let me try to Toto brief to
describe briefly present situation of
our countries I believe it will be
possibly complementary to some remarks
we've heard already during this session
with the last decade of the 20th century
poland and ukraine found themselves a
part of cooper's post-colonial cars or
the robert cooper made reference to the
post colonial territories of africa the
pacific region or Ozzy Asia it determine
ideas as successfully described the
post-soviet Central European
sphere we do have a whole wide spectrum
of possibilities beginning with the ex
gdr which was externally overtaken
budget ball based german republic that's
joining the fatherland moving down the
line we encountered the sub stage at the
check hungary and poland also
encountering difficulties but having
distinct success